good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast
happy Friday even though Friday it's not
even Friday because every day feels like
Friday cuz we're never leaving our
houses as we shouldn't as we should have
no but for us Friday means that tomorrow
we get to sleep in and I really am
jealous of all those work from homers to
get to roll over answer an email fall
back asleep push back their calls like I
can't wait to sleep in yes so it's been
a crazy week here at the morning toast
and at the world in general I hope
everyone is doing well I hope everyone
is staying quarantined because we are
hashtag alone together we are and we
also our hashtag the quarren scenes yeah
of course of course we are of course oh
my god
I'm Theo's here he's feeling you know hi
he was up all night testing people for
coronavirus and answering his DM is just
like giving good medical advice because
there's so much information out there so
much misinformation but there's so much
common-sense information that I just
feel like people aren't putting together
and that's why we have doctors like dr.
Theodore for Chapman who are here to
answer all of your burning questions um
in addition to the regular show you know
we got five stories for you we're gonna
recap our toasts movie of the day which
was the Hulu original Big Time
adolescence starring Pete Davidson which
was kind of weird and I have some
thoughts I have some thoughts but it's a
good choice I was glad to watch
something that I hadn't seen yet we also
are going to assign something new for
the weekend something longer and I think
you guys are gonna be excited about it
series so that's it what else what else
I don't know I'm just like you guys I'm
on day eight of the quarantines and I'm
actually really grateful to the toast
because I think like getting up every
day I'm putting on makeup and like
looking a little cute it's been so good
for my mental health and like even on
stories and so if it seems like I'm just
like doing so much better than I
probably am and I feel like you know
being in your pajamas all day and not
showering and not doing you're like just
doing your regular routine um I feel
like it really can be hard yeah I mean
you and I differ on this completely
because when we have to take a week off
from doing live shows and just do
podcasts you were like hating life like
not wearing makeup rolling out about in
the sweatshirt whereas I feel as though
that's where I thrived I think I was
like the funniest I'd ever been on those
podcast episodes like waking up extra
early and like having to put on lipstick
when I just don't feel beautiful that to
me is my definition of torture I know I
think if
you did like a full work week straight
in your house like no delineation
between pajamas and and and day clothes
not even just about makeup but just
about whatever your routine is like I
think I we just are in a very nice
position to be able to have that little
bit of structure that we usually have
totally I agree that like staying home
and having no delineation between like
night and day is traumatizing but I just
meant more like the makeup thing like if
I was still leaving my house without me
but for me like that makeup is that for
me but for other people it could be
working out and by the way I think I'm
about to crack because I think I need to
work out guess what I cracked you worked
out I bought an exerciser what's that um
it's like a very very small elliptical
but it's just for your feet and your
it's really really hard it's very high
intensity you're supposed to do 60
second intervals um which I can do like
I can commit to doing 60 seconds of a
workout and you just do it as much or as
little as you want it's very hard to
balance on so it's good for your core
Ben was like nagging me about working
out so he wants to get a yoga mat and I
would rather die than have a yoga mat in
my house so I had to find another option
Wow I think like a snitch and I might
you like a FaceTime workout today cuz I
don't even know how to workout in my
apartment I don't have fans or weights
or anything well you can do open fit
which is a sponsor here at the show they
have tons of workouts that don't require
and I've heard people are obsessed with
OBE our body electric it's like dance
classes or something I don't know maybe
I'll just learn another tick-tock Dan
it's like a high-intensity one and
that's that's really a workout I mean if
you see me after learning the renegade
like I'm full sweats yeah there's a
dance that I want to learn my whole like
like tab is all full of dances I want to
learn and like the slo-mo versions where
they teach them to you have you seen the
one it's really old but it's like my
hips stop button my neck is faucet and
they say I went into seven rings remix
but it's like it's aerobic the remix is
there's toga that's the best part of
tick-tock it's like obviously learning
the dances getting fun getting fit
getting healthy but learning all these
new songs I when I had my game night
like over a week ago I put on Spotify
top 40 because like of course I would
like to listen to how a country but I'm
having guests like I'll be I'll be
courteous and I knew every single song
on top 40 Spotify just from [ __ ]
Spotify I mean just from tik-tok yeah
feeling good like I should when in took
a walk around the neighborhood
right yeah Chad - that's all I know
there's so many good songs on tic TOCs
so I even realized that I'm learning new
music yeah it's very trending you'd come
over right that was on the top so if I'm
like how the [ __ ] do I know the words to
these songs yeah well Chuck crazy man
you know what else is getting me through
the quarren scenes these sweatpants
these are our morning toast sweatpants
the O's on me but they're part of a
merge drop that we did for the holidays
and we still have some in stock at chop
morning toast calm and I can't recommend
them highly enough I have two pairs so
that when one's in the wash I can wear
the other ones and they're just the most
comfortable things ever and they're also
great for tick-tock I wore them on -
yeah knocking like they give you that
like tick-tock potty and it makes your
dance moves look better so like if
you're just looking for a tick-tock hack
these suck can sorry I love those
sweatpants I used to have a pair and
then Ben took them and he wears them all
around the house it's so rude so they're
also unisex yeah and also I think
there's a bunch of items on sale at shop
morning toast are common if you guys
want to check that out yeah a good comfy
merch to lay around in we never do this
but we have a special birthday on the
toast here oh we do it is my best friend
Becky she's also a part of the TNN
family one of the redheads it's her
birthday today this is not how we
thought we would be celebrating we had a
whole plan and we didn't have a whole
plan it's just so funny because it's
like man plans God laughs and Corona
laughs corona laughs OH shout out it's
Taylor D oreos birthday I heard that as
well I think it's like we have so many
toasty birthdays maybe her birthday was
this weekend you didn't get to celebrate
and maybe you just need like a rendition
of happy birthday oh you mean a toastie
or or a cringy you are Fergie happy
birthday miss Prince I hope that made
you cringe on your birthday Taylor and
Becky happy birthday guys so my favorite
birthday song happy birthday to one that
won't get a suit
happy birthday to you happy birthday
happy birthday to you happy birthday to
ya happy birthday everyone I'm really
feeling for people whose birthdays are
in the quarantine Ben's birthday
in April which sounded far away when
this whole thing started but it's just
around the corner and it's looking like
we're gonna have to have an intimate
affair meet him and Theo at home which
sounds ideal
wow that does sound idea what more could
you need when you have Theo like
quarantine is a dream quarantine
quarantine is it's not a dream but it's
so much better with a dog and you know
our sister Margot she called me
yesterday and she was like should I cost
her a dog and I'm like excuse me Who am
I talking to
she said yeah like I'm alone and I feel
like what else am I gonna be doing with
my time and I could like just do
something good with my time and I was so
proud of her and she applied at social
tees and just let this be a an
announcement like if you were thinking
about fostering your dog not adopting
just fostering um now's the time look
into your local shelter well in one of
the toaster groups someone posted a
pop-up or abduction a king Charles
Cavalier named me Oh and he's also
happens to be a one-eyed fat and he's 11
months old and he's 11 months old and
his name is neo and and he's with Oh vo
and that's the dog that this Mitch means
she needs a one-eyed fox named neo oh my
god I mean do you know how much I would
die if someone in the family got a
[ __ ] dog I know I know but how would
like a Theo really loves being the
center of attention yeah I know I
actually think with the birth of
Olivia's child which I'm obviously
excited about it is gonna be a hard
adjustment for Theo like he will be
virtually irrelevant totally also
speaking of the birth of Olivia's child
one new episode of maternity leave is up
where she's revealing the gender of her
bed Bay and she's talking to her man's
and - we are filming something very
special with her this afternoon
hopefully for our patreon channel so
patron comm such a morning toast we are
working ot to deliver premium content
that's like more fun and different than
what we usually do because no you have
more time at home so we're trying to
make some great video content for you
guys head on over there and if you sign
up now you get so much content that will
like actually I think hours wise get you
through the weekend yeah so check it out
ok John Comyn Sasha morning to us thanks
guys
check it out check it out I also I know
we be kept like things that we're
watching but I think I'm gonna restart
succession I mean I did actually I
watched the first episode yesterday we
tried already seen and now I'm on the
second episode and I still don't love it
but I have nothing better to do and at
least it's like like it's bad but it's
good quality as opposed to the bold type
which is like quality that storyline bed
right
at wardrobe and lighting the whole thing
yeah yeah I feel that I watched little
fires everywhere which is everyone's
been talking about it because it's one
of the first projects Reese is doing
from hello sunshine she it's a book that
they turned into a TV series and I just
need to speak to the person at Hulu
whose decision it was to release it
three episodes a week your streaming
service so like don't don't try and do
something different like that's not what
we asked them you especially given the
climate we're living in like quarantine
like how dare you I know
actually the hutzpah for whoever made
this decision is an astronomical level
and I shame you and poopoo bad job I
just feel like maybe the powers that be
haven't seen yesterday's episode yet
where I implore you to just keep on
releasing content maybe release it early
batch it I think you'll find a lot of
success in that and that's what the
people want
so maybe just release all of little
fires everywhere it's so it's to me it's
a crazy thing to do as a streaming siren
it's like when Netflix did it with the
love is blind like I kind of understood
it was more of a reality show but still
really annoying this is a whole other
level of road and it's shame on you yeah
and I just started a new book and what's
Mitch and I are doing is we're trying to
read it together like page for page like
I'll tell her what chapter I'm up to and
then she'll catch up blah blah blah it's
called American royal so far it's cute
it's kind of similar to the last
redheads book of the month but um you
know if it ain't broke don't fix it so
true yes our redheads book of the month
is nothing to see here I'm so excited to
read it you know sophie turner was
reading it I heard I've heard such good
things a lot I think a lot of people
were like why why are we choosing this
book intro so weird Dana but that's her
vibe and I think that it's like good
good stuff so make sure to read it and
you episode of the redheads will be out
the first Thursday of April great I
can't wait can't wait okay should we get
right into it you know there's just like
so much happening in the world it's like
there's so much happening but they're so
little happening like my newsletter gets
sent out every morning and now they just
started doing two a day and it's like is
there more news than ever or less news
than I there's more news than ever but
less range like it's literally the only
thing people are talking about also a
lot of people are talking about the
weekend's album is that a story no
literally the entire thing is about
Bella Hadid like savage but also looks
so lovely
there's not one song about Selena Gomez
according to Twitter I forgot that they
did it but I
missed that time I don't know how like
Bella Hadid could have gotten back
together with the weekend like after
what he did to her like go into the Met
Gala was Selena Gomez just like that was
so crazy that was crazy I wish I could
have worked out and then the intricacies
of like Selena Gomez Taylor Swift Gigi
Hadid Bella Hadid like it's so close you
know I won different cause like a rift
in the friendship bill is not really
that detail like Gigi Taylor Kendall
came yeah but Kendall is like there's
such a separation into his life between
the Taylor and Gigi is best friends with
Kendall and she's best friends with
Taylor she's best friends with Taylor in
New York and she's best friends with the
Kendall in LA I don't know but sometimes
Kendall comes to New York Fashion Week
what is she gonna do unclear you hear
that um Ben told me this actually so
take it at face value it could be 100
percent incorrect actually you know what
I'm not gonna say what I was gonna say
sorry I just okay cool and I also wanted
to share that Kelsea Ballerini album is
out today yes and I listened to it this
morning and there are two songs that I
absolutely loved one was love me like a
girl okay and two was the one with Kenny
Chesney half of my hometown so good
there's also a song with Halsey on there
I did um you know I did get an early
look at them cuz I'm so annoying and
it's fantastic and I I've such a respect
for people who had albums coming out
like this month and didn't postpone them
like Sam Smith postponed and I totally
get it but it's just it's so vapid like
it's obviously only because like I'm the
press and the money when it's like
people need music now more than ever
yeah it's like and there's no like
reason for the greater good why you need
to postpone other than that this isn't
like the best time unless like you
couldn't get to finish the album
whatever feeling if you're a month out
from your album release date like it's
pretty much finished unless you're Kanye
yes so you're right so major kudos to
the weekend and Kelsea Ballerini for so
releasing them and let's support them
okay yeah and we do need music like the
days that I've listened to music during
this quarantine have been such more
positive days that's not English such
more positive yes that's definitely such
more positive days and it just makes you
like if you have something that you need
to do like put a soundtrack on like
catch a vibe clean it really it makes a
difference agreed it makes a difference
because it makes the world go around and
that's I think the message that gal
gadot failed to deliver yesterday
but I think the underlying message of it
was just like release your album yeah
definitely
okay I think it's time even though
obviously we have no clue if it's time
or the Fast Five story is that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast that's
true I actually have been eating a lot
of morning toast have in my bunker
because like all I eat is like toasted
avocado toast and I just like I have a
new appreciation for toast like I'm not
gonna lie putting a little honey on
toast is good you know honey but I need
you of the honey browser extension oh
hell yeah you know that honey is the
free online shopping tool that
automatically finds the best promo codes
and applies them to your cart and you
know how great it is it feels to save
but how does it feel to save with honey
it feels like sliding into a seat on the
train just before the doors closed I
have had honey since before they were
sponsored the toasters told me about it
it's basically a browser extension you
download I have it on Chrome and when
you're shopping online right before you
check out this little thing pops up it's
like this little honeypot he's like hey
[ __ ] you want to save some money and
you click the button and they literally
find every coupon code on the internet
and apply the one that applies to you
and just automatically save you money it
takes 10 seconds um they've found over
18 million members saved over two
billion dollars that honey supports over
30,000 stores online so if you're
shopping at Macy's Target Sephora Best
Buy they're adding more every day but
you can save money at your favorite
stores users love honey and has over a
hundred thousand five-star reviews on
the google chrome store using honey
feels pretty great it's like a little
daily victory plus it's free to use and
installs in just a few seconds get honey
for free at join honey calm / toast
that's join honey calm / toast thank you
honey for sponsoring today's episode get
honey for free with join honey calm /
toast can did Oh free love it that songs
a classic classic actually you know what
everyone is actually getting connected
for free with education connection you
know what I was thinking I feel so bad
for the parents who are like
homeschooling their kids right now who
are just running amuck like I wish we
had some sort of like educational bone
in our body and we could like do
teaching classes you know you except we
can't ya know I feel as though I might
be like the least qualit like I should
never become a teacher I understand but
like imagine like we have this platform
we could like do stuff with your kids
like reading you know teaching now for
bet like I'm
where we're at you know I think it was
the right rate lane we did bit like if
we had if we could then we would and we
should but we can't so we shan't am II
went I understand we definitely went we
definitely went first up Lana Del Rey
and her cop boyfriend Shawn Larkin have
broken up the quarantine got to them
first want to break yep they are they're
breaking and then what do you do in your
in quarantine someone you break up but
you can't leave their house well with
celebrities I find especially like
someone like Lana Del Rey who's very
low-key I'm sure they broke up a few
weeks ago when like now we're just
formally announcing it probably like
strategically during the quarantine
dramas like no one's really talking
about it and then like the quarantines
over and we just like understand that
her and her boyfriend are broken up I
know but they just stepped out together
at the Grammys I think there's not that
much time to go from like deciding to
make your relationships so public and
then just calling it quits honestly
maybe he broke up with her because she
wore a short sleeved dress to the
Grammys it's possible stranger things
have happened
you know what else I was thinking about
was sorry speaking of stranger things
did you see that got good hope she just
couldn't wait yesterday she was like
sharing people's instagrams like if
you're singing imagine like let me sing
and someone put up a very very old video
of Milly Bobby Brown singing imagine
like from her YouTube or something and
Gago to shared it like thinking it was a
real person me like this is beautiful
Thank You Claudia that's beautiful
marina that's funny
what was I gonna say oh I feel bad for
couples who like just decided they're
gonna get divorced but they haven't
moved out yet you know they like filed
for separation but they like didn't use
on the couch but they didn't like get an
apartment yet and now they have to live
together
that's the couples I was thinking about
and they can't make any progress in
finding an apartment because like
everyone's working from homes right and
also they're not celebrities so they
can't just be like whisked off to like
Chateau Marmont yeah maybe they're like
staying with a friend maybe but like we
have to be quarantined right so you'd
have to like the person would have to
commit to letting you stay there for at
least two weeks that sounds like a great
movie and then of course at the end of
the movie they fall back in love and
they don't get divorced and you know
thanks to Corona
they found love again yeah I mean I can
be artistic I'm not even a filmmaker but
the artistic inspiration from
coronavirus is it's a no like I wonder
how many movies books like what are we
gonna get yeah like people working on
their art will get like fictional movies
and non-fictional like obviously the
saga will be turned into a movie but
then also will get like you know the
husband and wife
who are living upstairs downstairs and
they met in the kitchen yeah like we're
like a hallmark movement it's a little
dark for hallmark but like a lifetime
original like warranty I have to think
of the name but I'm think of it I'll be
the star and then also a Lifetime movie
where you know a couple's quarantined
together it starts out good but your
quarantine with a murderer like The
Shining I didn't see it but what I don't
watch any scary movies I've never seen
one oh my god I don't like scary movies
either but you've never seen the shine
I've never seen one scary movie what do
you consider scary like horror thriller
whatever like garage G vibes scaring
like gone girl juicy gone girl yes I did
that's not a scary that's nobody Tyler
yeah it's dark and twisted but it's not
like yeah I've only seen one of those
The Grudge and it literally coming up at
night but you saw the shining but see
that's not that's not like a gory that's
a thriller it's like a murder mystery
almost okay not mystery but it's like
there's no monsters under the bed it's
like Jack Nicholson goes crazy and tries
to kill his family oh because he was
quarantined but them in the middle of
nowhere yeah like all those monsters on
the bed hills have eyes Annabelle yeah
I'm an evil heart our normal activity
yeah I don't [ __ ] with that I don't [ __ ]
with that but I definitely [ __ ] with
like a crime thriller I don't know what
that's how it categorized the shining
but it's really actually don't watch it
during the quarantine because it's
literally about a quarantine and a man
hates his family so much after being
quarantined with them in a hotel upstate
that he literally just decides to kill
them and I'm getting there with my
husband so I can't watch them but
because it might push me to the edge be
really careful about the stuff that you
watch sometimes at like different stages
of your life feels like it might inspire
you to make a change that like you
weren't actually ready for yeah that's
why when I watch um younger I'm always
feeling like I need to go out every
night and get drunk and it literally
like [ __ ] with my brain well yeah well
that's good you know that's a good
positive change but you could watch I
don't know girlfriends guide to divorce
and thank you and divorce life to
fabulous this looks fun yeah totally
it's cinema is influential you guys so
just be careful what you're watching is
Netflix is now doing the top 10 thing
which we reported on this and I'm loving
and I just want to say like I got that
update on my Netflix but I didn't get
the update of auto trailers off so I'm
just upset about auto trailers off it's
um like auto play yeah yeah no I I still
have that
no no but like
they they play the trailer but like
sometimes they would play the movie oh
yeah sometimes you finish a movie and
they just play another movie there or
they start a series like I think Hulu
was about to start Ugly Betty like after
I finished an episode of the bull-type
Wow or no alertly
after I finished Big Time adolescence
that's what it was big time Big Time
adolescence I have a lot of thoughts on
okay we'll get to it but anyway Shawn
Larkin revealed the break-up news in a
profile with the New York Times about
his reality TV series live PD saying him
and Lana remain amicable quote right now
we're just friends we still talk and
whatnot we just have busy schedules
right now well not anymore
okay's the police officer I'm sure he's
busy he's so handsome yeah it was an
interesting thing for Lana Del Rey to
like do you know date outside of her her
category of celebrity and sad that it's
over they were cute even though she did
wear short sleeve dress which is
probably what ruined the relationship it
was like she was so happy in her
relationship she just wore a short
sleeve dress like sometimes you just are
so happy that like you don't think about
the important thing you let yourself go
yeah yeah that's true I feel that yeah
what was Mikey Rogers excuse uh um I
just hate short sleeves dresses like I'm
not a style expert like whatsoever
Rodgers excuse was that long it was
doing it and no Maggie Rogers excuse was
that it was vintage Chanel so like you
just think that something vintage Chanel
is gonna be beautiful
and it was it just like was nothing of
the sort Yvonne Coco Chanel makes
mistake I don't even know what what
brand Lana's was but whatever it was
it's not it couldn't help the situation
I believe it was if I'm remembering
correctly
she bought che oh damn well even she
bought Shane makes mistakes
okay ready for our next story like it's
just such fun flirty news what Morgan
Stewart confirmed she's been dating dr.
Phil's son Jordan McGraw for three
months and if you're a toaster you
already knew this but we weren't gonna
put it on blast because we have the most
respect for Morgan Stewart yeah we knew
this three months ago so like get with
it but thanks he news for the breaking
news allegedly
yeah well Morgan broke the news on her
own terms in her own time on Instagram
live which is where all the news is
going down these days I mean I'm I'm in
the press more than ever I don't know my
my live from two nights ago like kind of
broke the internet it's crazy what lives
can do when people have nothing else to
do
I I did another live yesterday and I had
a slew of guests Heather McDonald came
on was talking all about her Jim Bellino
lawsuit what did she say
she just said she's so happy and now
it's like such a big deal for
casters everywhere um I had I had anti
grammar came on and sink he sat down
this piano and saying keep your head up
it was really inspirational for people i
had Maddie Taylor Jeffery stars
assistant and I was just like jojo's
Lauren teamed with Jeffery no she was
working like a few days ago but now
she's like stopped don't she live at the
house I thought so too but she wasn't
there so I don't know um I had so many
other people and I literally can't
remember Oh Tonya rad talking all about
her Newman's and it was just it was kind
of like I don't know groundbreaking and
then before bed I was like seeing so
many people were live and then I was
like hopping on there's so I got on with
Chris and Lauren Lane I was just being
like literally so thirsty for people's
lives I got on Vanessa ray from Blue
Bloods like I was just being so annoying
co-opting people's lives but I'm living
for it I I take my call the [ __ ] I spoke
about Instagram live a few days ago
that's good I don't ok well the e news
nightly pop host confirmed the romance
during an Instagram live video on
Wednesday in the video McGraw was seen
standing in the background while fans
flooded the comments with sweet notes
about the cute couple so they are
quarantining together in Malibu it's
like so fabulous and so Morgan so
fabulous and they shared a bit about how
they got together it turns out they
dated like 10 years ago but he broke up
with her and then she started dating her
now ex Brandon and got married etc and
then they reconnected a few months ago
and it's been bliss ever since yeah it
has been bliss ever since but like I'm
sure Brendan like wants to die right is
there anything worse than like your
significant other acts like getting back
together with someone that they dated
before you because it's like oh I never
stopped thinking about that yeah and
it's like was our whole relationship a
lie yeah yeah pretty much whatever I'm
so happy for her and like yes get that
phil mcgraw money okay oh for sure
but richard smight on television even
though the inside of his house is super
weird like morgan can change you know
when it's like not only is he dr. Phil's
son which is enough yeah but then he
also is a musician which is just like
attractive and he's on tour with the
Jonas Brothers so now you're part of the
Jay sisters you're like Jay cousin and I
just couldn't think of any better
situation for her I just I just love
Morgan and I just want the best for her
so if she's happy I'm happy
100% hundred percent she's happy I'm
happy and she seems really happy yeah
and she's just everything of the sort
and I want to be here in like skin
where her and I bought that boat taking
another clutch just because she has it
and like a litter it cost me an arm and
a leg but like I'm okay with that
she has it in every color color no I
know I'm like so jealous I know but like
she deserves it she deserves it all she
does she really deserts the world she
deserves the world and like a home in
Malibu to quarantine with her man and
that's what she has yeah drinking Aperol
spritz is just being so fabulous so
fabulous like even her quarantine looks
are so fabulous yes she doesn't let
herself get in the rut of being of
working for a while working for mom also
she's into new relationships like you
really can't slide into like ugly
sweatpants yeah like you still have to
put on your your glasses or like your
Morgan Stewart sport with a collared
shirt yes and your Bottega Veneta
sandals yes also I feel like a lot of
relationships obviously marriages will
be made or broken but like new
relationships like at this 3-month stage
if your quarantining together by the
time we come out of this like you will
either be engaged or single it's gonna
speed it up a lot of relationships
because you're dating someone for three
months you see them maybe a few times a
week no now you're like living with them
you're basically married so it will make
or break you and I and I hope that
you're made I hope that you're made but
if it breaks you then it just wasn't
meant to be and I'm happy for you and
you didn't waste your time I do and you
know then a lot of other couples are
waking up and there's going to be new
singles on the market yes it's one way
to shake up the dating pool yeah
dating apps are gonna be flooded in like
three months they should be flooded
right now now's a great time to talk to
people like make plans for August and
whoo I can't believe it like I I refuse
mentally like I'm just taking this one
week at a time that could very well
might go until August but like I can
only put like I think one day in front
of the next yeah it's like that song
from frozen like just do the next right
thing or it's like that iconic song from
Jordin Sparks just take one step at a
time
there's no need to rush it's like
bowling
too fast or falling in love sometimes
Jordin Sparks like there are no words
besides like can you genuinely tell me
how I'm supposed to breathe with no air
you know it seemed possible
memmer enjoyed in Sparks and Jason do
Earl are worthy iconic couple that we
wish would get married and then they
broke up and now like nothing was ever
the same nothing was ever the same but
I'm so obsessed with Jason Derulo tic
sorry I'm so obsessed with his tic TOCs
like everything about him is just you
know why it's a special formula to be a
celebrity on taking on tik-tok because a
lot of people coming on are just like
singers and pop stars who are obviously
using it to promote their music and
put up like dumb stuff in between but
Jason Derulo doesn't really have any
music and he just hops on there
genuinely because he loves to sing and
dance and I'd love to see someone using
the platform as an expression of their
creativeness you know you're not like
thirst monster here's my challenge to my
new song show me how you use it oh
there's that version of a celebrity on
tick-tock like trying to exploit their
music but then there's also like the
Jessica Alba's like in who just do that
one dance I she's so out of control on
Tik Tok I need to take her phone when
there's the Jason Derulo's and the
Ashley Tisdale who make it their own
yeah and who are not there for anything
other than just to have a good time to
show off their skills remind people why
they love them but then there's another
version it's like a bebe Rexha Joe Jonas
who they got on the app to start a
challenge for like what a man got to do
but then they stayed with consistent
good content and that's literally all I
can ask for I understand that everyone
needs to work but then there's the duo
liepa's who literally have never posted
anything other than her life let's get
physical challenge and you know what I
don't I don't respect that at all I
think that's rude yeah and there's
almost like the JLo who falls into that
Joe Jonas category of like okay I'm
gonna start with my Super Bowl challenge
but now I'm gonna show you my whole
family actually she falls into a new
category of kids who are people who are
only on there because of their kids well
then so that's where the Venn diagram
crosses with Jessica Alba yeah and a rod
is in there too and so is Courtney Cox
like she's always and laura dern like
and Mark Cuban yes right so I like dad I
like the people who won't show up on
their kids and they're pretending to be
like funny and thirsty but they're good
they're kids got them there I respect
that yeah and it's like they won't let
their kids have their own take talks and
by the way it's because tick tock won't
let you be on the platform if you're not
13 which is why Mason got kicked off Oh
mystery has been solved so the parents
have a page and are able to share it
with their kids I think it's very nice I
got it okay that makes a lot of sense
I'm loving the kid parent crossover on
Tech Talk that's some of my favorite
content yeah okay next story
Josh GAD wants you to know it's okay to
cry okay Josh GAD took to Twitter on
Thursday for some light crying amid the
corona virus pandemic with the intention
of reassuring his followers that it's
okay to be in your feelings right now
wearing a hat that references frozen to
a movie that was very confusing for both
campers and counselors oh I didn't
understand that hat I was like is that a
Sex in the City reference I took
Samantha Samantha question mark yeah
okay I saw frozen to it and this is how
confusing it was because I don't get the
Hat ah that's funny um
like sounds familiar but I just can't
put my finger on it I haven't seen
frozen chip maybe I well during the
quarantine who knows oh maybe there was
like a little swirl of air and he called
it Samantha
I thought he called it Gayle I can't
camp which was a Christmas gift from his
co-star Kristen Bell gab begins his
video by saying I was going to cry for a
second and I was gonna do it by myself
and then I thought you know what it's
important for everybody to understand
that we're all going through so much
uncertainty right now we're gonna get
through it and it's hard and I'm
emotional because I hate seeing our kids
deprived of their normal lifestyles and
not being able to understand why all of
this is happening so quickly by the way
he says this a lot slower than I am
video but I'm also emotional because of
all the incredible things that so many
of you are doing out there on a daily
basis okay you know I'm never one to
step on anyone's toes especially when
they're getting in their feelings and I
absolutely love Josh GAD like so scared
I'm his biggest fan
like I love Gaston you know how like
important that food you know how
important that whole really like we are
guests on in the food like in our own
different ways that the are where each
part cast in part Lefou and I think
that's why we related to it so much and
so much of his work has really like been
important to me like I'm not joking Olaf
is a cultural icon and like a source of
positivity and inspiration like
especially for kids everywhere and
that's job and that's on Josh GAD and
also the Wedding ringer is one of the
best movies yes all-time yes and that's
on Josh GAD and Kevin Hart so I just I
don't want to say anything negative
without putting so much positivity out
there like because I really feel like
Josh GAD is a force in the world but and
also Book of Mormon like he originated
well it's everything of the sort he's a
force for good and I feel it's very
similar to the gal gadot thing like the
message I get it like everyone should
just be like you know in their feelings
I guess but I don't know there was just
something about the video being like so
close up to his face and like it the
cringe enos level was like astronomical
and then like this strategically placed
tear on his cheek I just I I don't I
don't support it and I'm sorry that's so
hard for me as someone who just
automatically supports everything Josh
GAD does not only do I not supported I'm
extremely offended by it and I just
think that every celebrity should just
stop okay like I like I just I don't
need inspiration from these people you
know they might we know what I find
inspiring like literally Simon hook like
hired a musician to stand out
at his grandma's window in her nursing
home because it was her birthday and
they couldn't go visit her like that's
inspiring like real people doing real
things like I just I don't need video
compilations of people like trying to
inspire me you know yes I find
inspiration and things that are
inspirational not in videos that are
trying to be yeah trying to make you be
inspired and also I can't relate to
celebrities like who are in there like
mansions huge houses that they never
even need to leave because everything is
there and they're talking about how
they're bored you know and like how
their children are surprised with like
their basketball court in their pool
like they're fine yeah no I I told and
they're like going live on Instagram and
all so I'm just so glad they were able
to do this show because like people who
are doing their shows like from their
homes are Lady Couric like in her
basement but I know so that that's being
streamed on TV like that's reason to do
it but like they're I think they're
trying to do like The Tonight Show from
like Jimmy Fallon's home or like they're
doing like have him go lie that on
Instagram and do the show
like know people are floundering like
especially businessman media yeah I
could just imagine like if that used to
be my job like what I would have to be
doing to like get people inspired and
talking and like nobody wants talking
shows one watch TV know that nobody
wants to talk and they don't even they
really don't want to watch the news like
it's so depressing yeah but at least the
news are on TV I have to say something
so I knew that there was a press
conference yesterday um like about the
coronavirus and I don't really know like
where to watch a press conference so um
I was just like scrolling and I found it
on CNN and then I'd left CNN on for like
a few hours like I don't know I was just
there and like I thought we had
technical problems like literally it's
the most legitimate like it's CNN
literally they were like skyping in
these people like from their bathrooms
they were frozen they had to keep like
connecting people via Skype
disconnecting connecting the girl had
her piece in her hair she couldn't hear
the guy she was literally like holding
her finger in her it was such a [ __ ]
show and it made me laugh so hard
because it's like I thought we had
problems like look about real networks
of their problems or it was hysterical
that's hysterical that sounds like the
CNN New Year's Eve special with Anderson
and when they were like skyping in
different people and then they talk over
each other because of the delay and it's
just painful it was so funny and like
justice for that anchor she was like
running this show and it was just like a
sinking ship and she was trying so hard
and I respect it says I respect the
hustle I do I do I do
okay next story I'm obsessed with one
because
it's great news too because there's a
bit of a shark tank tie-in
oh yes yes the first US company has
announced an upcoming home Kovan 19 test
everly well a home testing company that
offers dozens of lab tests to consumers
and was also on Shark Tank though they
did not get a deal even though it was
the best idea ever
so useful so informative so smart and
then if you watch the episode that they
were on like the dumbest company's ever
got deals but ever really well did not
but by the way they didn't get a deal
because they didn't like the idea the
company the girl had like a million
dollars and she didn't really need their
money she was like a shark tank gold
digger no she wasn't like they just
didn't want to get into the medical
field like they just no one wanted to
touch this because there is a lot of
risk in answer oh yeah and you know she
could have been Elizabeth home right
right very nice right
but anyways I really well justice for
them is adding a Koba 19 test beginning
on March 23rd given the slow rollout of
tests into for testing for Cova 19 in
the US and concerns about spreading the
disease at home testing could help to
diagnose more cases after initially
limiting testing to one provided by the
CDC and conducted at state and local
public health labs the FDA allowed
certified labs including commercial lab
testing company to develop and
distribute cope at 19 tests on February
29th
though other private companies have been
involved with creating tests for Koba 19
this is the first company to offer its
tests directly to consumers fabulous I
mean this is like the this is our cross
to bear in America it's like we have the
technology we're so smart we did it you
know
Kove it has been around for a few months
and we already got an at-home testing it
but it's 135 dollars like that's crazy
but it's like we're so glad we have it
but like what the [ __ ] 135 dollars
I wonder if it's covered by insurance ya
know or the fact that like all
coronavirus testing is going to be paid
for by the government is what the
President had said oh I wonder if this
is included oh I don't know those
drive-through um yes test centers are
great
I watched what's-his-name KFC for a bar
stool he got tested I hate to go like
6:00 in the morning and wait on this
like long treacherous line but you don't
get out of your car and they just do it
and it takes ten seconds and then you're
bouncing they call you in 30 days yeah
those are genius I mean I've always been
into a drive-thru like for a forever do
if you don't have a car or a license
oh my god imagine yes so funny but I
feel like an uber driver would be like
you think you have Corona I got the [ __ ]
outta my face oh yeah I don't know I
guess I would just walk up yeah right
but like that's what you're not supposed
to do because they're supposed to
protect ya nurses I know but actually
what would I do I don't know I don't
know I think I would just try and get an
uber maybe like get a test for my driver
- yeah maybe it'd be nice to be like if
you get him a test he'll drive you
through yeah I wanna have to find an
uber driver who wants to be testing we
go together yeah yeah yeah you carpool
carpool it would also be hard for me to
like go through a drive-thru and then
just like not end up with a McFlurry
yeah there should be like a station out
at the end where you get a cup of coffee
or something yeah because I don't know
very painful to a test I've seen some of
the videos it's so far up your nose it
touches your brain I saw something
Navy's video oh yeah that's what showed
me what it looks like what's so funny
well not funny is that every single
person who gets it done like it's so
painful and your eyes water so the
second they take the thing out of your
nose you're touching your eyes in your
face which is like the exact opposite of
what you're supposed to do oh that is
ironic ironic it's not funny but it's a
little it's a little silly okay
fifth and vine the story a little more
good news Walmart Dollar Tree and
7-eleven want to hire nearly two hundred
thousand workers because the corona
virus pandemic continues to gun Walmart
the largest private employer in the
United States plans to hire 150,000
temporary workers by the end of May as
the kernel virus pandemic continues to
sweep through the country the company
said it is hiring the associates to work
in stores clubs dish clubs
a I don't want to go to the club I don't
want to watch everybody around me trying
to hook up and say stuff they don't mean
and get drunk and get she is that the
one there who can get cheap I was with
this more I go it's like you get cheap
on your drunk not me but I I guess
people get cheap at the club like no one
wants pay for the table everyone's
mysteriously disappear yeah like looking
for someone to buy them insuring click
buy your own drink [ __ ] hey get that
debit card that's true
weights go back to this story because I
have someone say so they're hiring
associates to work in its clubs and it
stores distribution centers and
fulfillment centers that's so great I
mean yeah I feel like once this is all
over I will remember like
brands stepped-up and what brands did
not and it's gonna change me as a
consumer like I was again I know I keep
referencing but Sara Foster has been
doing this thing on her Instagram and
this morning she highlighted one of her
followers who teamed her anonymously
that she works at Dillard's and
Dillard's has not closed one store the
entire corporate corporate office is
completely open and they sent out a memo
to the employees telling them how to
respond to people if they ask them why
they're still working
wow I'm the one hand it's like wow we
need to self quarantine like social
distance hunker down but on the other
hand it's like okay well these people
didn't lose their jobs I don't know you
have no but like in the corporate office
like there's no reason that people in
corporate offices cannot be working from
home everything they do is on their
computer that's true and then when it
comes to a retail store that's obviously
like a brand buy brand thing but to not
even at the top like do not even make
any genius it's so irresponsible it's so
irresponsible and just like treating
your employees like [ __ ] so I will
remember brands that stepped up like CVS
is stepping up Walmart is stepping up
like I will shop at these stores Delta
being so good to their customers
refunding their and rating their change
fees like I will remember this like when
all of this is over how brands reacting
crises really makes an impact impact on
me as a consumer it's like if you're in
charge of a brand like [ __ ] off yeah
like Amazon Whole Foods yeah well not I
used to be a really big shopper at Whole
Foods
really I've literally been to Whole
Foods three times in my life and there's
three times and honestly it was actually
kind of nice um but now after this it's
just supposed to be healthy and like
literally bought a box of mini donuts
and ate them as I walked around the
store but they did ever really really
nice orchid that lasts me a long time
and was only $30 so for that I think
they're good but I've actually and I
grew up right near one like I have been
to Whole Foods three times in my life
yeah me too and I got some really good
cheese and like a pie that was flames
you know I got I went before New Year's
and like they were not helpful at all
like I was just being sent around the
store like I'm it like a chicken with
her head cut off yeah and like they have
those lines where they like send you but
it seems like so biased I got on a line
once and like literally a million lines
got called until nine yeah no I think
that the I like that they're trying to
change the line system because it's not
a perfect system but theirs is
definitely a little computer-generated
like what how do they know how many
pieces do it's rigged
yeah it's like they have a camera and
someone's looking at you being like I'm
gonna make her suffer yeah totally like
you look like a [ __ ] like you do
actually have like a resting [ __ ] face
so if you're not smiling you look at me
and
yeah yeah busy official coronavirus a
hand signal okay so let's let's jump
into our recap let's jump right in but
before I do I just want to let everyone
know because you guys have heard us talk
about Yamahas conferencing phones this
week we finally got around and we are
not looking back the reviews are in and
they're rave and if you watch Jackie's
um a home tour on patreon she's like
such a cute little set up with her
Yamaha conferencing so cute you guys it
makes you feel like you're legit working
from home like on a conference call
meetings meetings meetings like let's go
like working from home is actually great
but the lack like you can't hear anyone
on the calls and you can't like get up
and let go to the bathroom and if you
sneeze in the kitchen your husband gives
you a look yeah but so the Yamaha
products are so easy to use we no longer
have to use the speaker on our cell
phone now that all of our meetings are
being moved virtually we're so glad we
have this we feel like Ben is going to
steal it many of us are still navigating
the new reality of working or learning
from home whether it's face-to-face
meetings or a classroom that has turned
virtual you can ensure that every word
is heard with quality audio from Yamaha
they're conferencing division has the
right tools to improve your at-home
experience whether it's a speakerphone a
video sound bar or wearable microphone
with no real end date in sight the
reality is that what this could go on
for a while if you're a manager and you
need to get this for your team if not
send the link to your manager and ask
them to expense it not only can you use
it now you can continue to use it when
business is back to normal the link to
get these products is you see Yamaha
comm slash toast for 10% off all their
work from home devices and products
that's letter U letter C dot Yamaha why
am i H a.com slash toast thanks to I
maja for being everything we need while
working from home totally love it ok
big-time adolescence Hulu original
starring Pete Davidson and a bunch of
nobodies
except for Machine Gun Kelly who was my
absolute favorite god what a hottie who
Noddy
no I'm telling you I didn't know I told
you I knew I didn't know I just kind of
like a lump him in with like GE Z and Z
and Justin Bieber they're not the same
and he is something else he's tall he's
something of the sort I wish he had had
a little bit more of a role like maybe a
love interest I don't know something but
I just enjoyed him being there Pete
Davidson like I just never get to see
him you know any mean it was you know to
see him for 90 minutes like on SNL he
shows up for 10 seconds he doesn't have
an Instagram like I've never seen his
face yeah
he's good he's a good actor he's funny
it was it a Judd Apatow movie it
definitely gave me the vibe it gave me
that I remember when like back in the
day when Judd Apatow was you know like
banger banger banger banger banger like
all those movies like pineapple Express
like they just weren't my bike all this
like stone or culture like it's just not
very glam no um and this movie was
making me feel that way like take a
shower yeah I do think obviously Pete
Davidson is a great actor but he wasn't
playing like a scholar he was really
playing like a version of himself yeah
and I do think that like if Pete
Davidson never became like a famous
comedian like he would be that guy yeah
so it wasn't hard for him to play you
know but he was like a cute story of
campers and counselors and how like it
should have been called big-time camper
counselor yeah and like you know the
campers take care of the counselors and
the counselors take care of the campers
but it's on the camp counselors to like
look out for the campers and he wasn't
being a good counselor no and the end
was getting really frustrating when he
was literally turning this kid into a
criminal and of course like I was
responsible for themselves but this kid
was a [ __ ] loser who just like wanted
to be liked by Pete Davidson and the
fact that Pete Davidson couldn't see
that and like wasn't really looking out
for the best interests of Moe was
frustrating yeah it was frustrating cuz
they could have had something beautiful
and instead like he got a tattoo and
then the kid with the chapped lips was
weird because they address the chapped
lips at one point in the movie they were
like you know my friend Stacey like have
lips like oh yeah why didn't he just get
some aqua for I don't know maybe there
wasn't budget for an aqua for crazy it
was really unlike it was just it took
away from ya very completely it did the
parents were so annoying like they were
bothering me so much because honestly
III blame them to be honest I don't know
why like it was in the beginning of the
movie it was just like normal that he
was hanging out with his kid ten years
older than him and they allowed it for
so long so of course it was gonna go bad
like they were the camp counselors not
looking out for their camper yeah
totally they were like the camp
directors and the dad was just like such
a loser yeah he was and he he like felt
like a loser like I really blame him
yeah it's just a weird story like this
just stuff like that happened like see
girls hang out with sixteen years oh I
didn't know what it was about and I just
thought like
this is just to me unrealistic like this
do it just doesn't work like that yeah
like okay maybe you like our kid who
like loves her sister's boyfriend but
like the big breakup and that he never
comes back yeah he's not sticking around
for you but I guess he was taking around
cuz he like never really stopped loving
the sister yeah but then okay so he was
using the cam bird oh yeah and then the
ending was so depressing like him in the
the fast food store like just not
like he had no passion yeah goals yeah
he's gonna start a podcast
that was funny that was funny um yeah
I'm glad that we watch it because I feel
like it was a cute movie and it was like
we would have watched you movie equally
dumb but one that we'd already seen yeah
I'm glad that it was one that I hadn't
seen it was fine how much you think um
Hulu paid you Davidson for that no clue
no clue but it's just like so
interesting he's very tall Davidson was
working on a movie with Judd Apatow I
wonder if that's the winner or if we
should be excited about it I've seen Jed
Apatow I was like named in the credits
and I feel like I would have remembered
if I did okay that's all on my phone a
lot so it's so hard for me to say oh no
the king of Staten Island is the moon
that sounds working on with Judd Apatow
it's a semi autobiographical comedy
drama about Pete Davidson growing up in
Staten Island including losing his
father during 9/11 Wow and entering the
world of stand-up comedy that sounds
great I think it's gonna be similar to
trainwreck how like Amy Schumer made
Trina act like some what about her yeah
that was such a good movie um maybe she
really needs to come out of the new
movie because she made two bangers and
then that terrible one with Goldie Hawn
and I'm George I'm ready for a new Amy
Schumer movie yeah me too
he was like a Netflix one she does have
a deal with Netflix yeah IMDB what she's
up to
oh I love checking people's IMDB he's
like further like a modernist project
when I was younger I'd be like who cares
about what's in production like I just
want to see the movies and now I'm like
such an insider that's so funny I mean
what does it say she's working out I
feel like she's not working like I think
she's just so happy being a mom she got
like what it loves it like 11 million
dollars from her Netflix special like
that took like one day to film okay
in pre-production is a TV series called
love Beth where she's a writer I'm sorry
okay actress love Beth she's in and the
humans is in post-production
what's the humans I know it's in post
it's a movie do they not give you any
other details um in set inside a pre-war
duplex in downtown Manhattan
the humans follows the course of an
evening in which the blank family
gathers together to celebrate
Thanksgiving darkness falls outside the
crumbling building mysterious things
start to go bump in the night and family
tensions reach a boiling point I'm not
interested in mysterious thing no that
sounds like a murder mystery yeah damn
we need a new image humor movie but that
king of Staten Island actually does
sound very very good so I look very much
I'm looking forward to seeing
yes I'm very much looking forward to
justice being served so I watched the
first three episodes of little fires
everywhere like this town Shaker Heights
Ohio like we need to move there like
it's just mansions on mansions on
mansions like and it's so nice and
they've it's like a really strict like
is giving me like Stepford Wives vibe
like the grass is not allowed to be
higher than six inches are like the town
finds you like it's just very
prestigious the house is so cute
Kerry Washington is like rough around
the edges single mom and her and Reese
Witherspoon like butting heads and then
always I don't spoil I'm not I'm gonna
head in like Kerry Washington just like
puts her ass where it doesn't belong and
literally ruins everything they were
having a nice thing like the families
were starting to burn check it was gonna
be a nice show and then Kerry why she
didn't have to put her nose where it
didn't belong damn okay I'm gonna watch
it but should I wait until it's all out
like yeah my mistake with myth millions
and with love is violence yes wait but
like while we're on this show like it is
our job to like talk about was coming on
and like people are watching it and like
it's only watched it because everyone
was talking about it and I thought it
would be like left behind if I wasn't
yeah I mean it is our job and I watch a
lot of [ __ ] I don't want to watch so we
could talk about on the show but I also
want to enjoy my life and watch a series
as I see fit
Sophia wait and so I'm gonna wait so if
you guys want to watch it that's not our
official recommendation for toast movie
of the weekend our toast content of the
weekend is a new series that comes out
today on Netflix called self-made
starring Octavia Spencer and it's the
story of the first self-made mill be
male millionaire in America and I think
it looks amazing and it's season 1 just
drop today first african-american
self-made millionaire Adam CJ Walker I
see the first self-made female self-made
millionaire ok on Google it says a
chronicle of the incredible story of
madam CJ Walker who was the first
african-american self-made millionaire
on Netflix description it says it says
Oh according to NBC News
Netflix is self a self-made isn't
inspired enough by madam CJ Walker the
reviews are in there they don't look so
good this is the Netflix description an
african-american washer woman rises from
poverty to build a beauty Empire I love
it and become the first female self-made
millionaire first a millionaire based on
a true story also Tiffany Haddish is in
it blair Underwood is in it and I love
him he's the doctor that Miranda goes
out
the Knicks doctor wait Miranda Hobbs
goes out with the doctor the next doctor
dr. Robert yeah oh my god I love him I
got him he's a very underrated character
in the sense that if it were for Steve
like he was arguably like the most
eligible bachelor ever featured on the
show
hundred percent doctor for the next he
loved Miranda so much he made that
cookie for her and told her that he
loved her only after two weeks because
he knew what he wanted cuz he's a real
man love that okay I'm excited about
that Octavia Spencer's everything in the
sword and I'm looking forward to a
series
instead of a movie cuz like the movies
have been fun but it's just not enough
time like the whole day to watch one
movie and it's only 90 minutes oh yeah I
know I'm excited for the series and also
I think I might read little fires
everywhere before yeah because every
time I read a really good buck I'm like
oh I wish I could just watch the movie
right now and then I can watch it and
then we can do a little compare and
contrast yeah maybe I can you get there
on your Kindle of course I can get
everything on my Kindle I love that
phrase I love my Kindle okay so you see
that I cooked last night you know what I
did did you make a piece of salmon I
made two pieces of salmon one for me and
one for my husband and I made green
beans Amandine with Parmesan and almond
almond Ian yeah and honestly I cooked
the salmon to perfection it was the best
piece of salmon you would have loved it
I put a little too much lemon on it no
grad was my first time ever couldn't
fish on my own mm-hmm and I crushed it
well I'm so happy for you been cooked
for me made tacos so good yeah it was
part of I'm okay I'll just I won't lie
to you guys cuz I love you and you know
it was a home chef meal but it's still
count it counts it totally got second
fish there were just instructions but he
around structions yes and they were
portioned ingredients it counts it
totally counts that leesook itself no it
didn't yeah it says did your house smell
like [ __ ]
no actually it's okay it was a nice kind
of fish they sent oh you're good
yeah and I have two more home chef meals
and I'm excited to make them because um
like that's exactly what I need to be
doing right now like using my kitchen
making some fresh food and stop eating
like burnt toast in my bunker so where
is um I don't know what I was about to
say what I was gonna say is that this is
our final show of the week we are
wrapping up do you many like
inspirational words you wanna leave with
people yes I actually I really do I'm so
glad that we could be here with you guys
this week it's been definitely a weird
[ __ ] week but I think keeping as much
structure and normalcy and
our lives and entertainment as possible
so thank you guys all for giving us you
know this opportunity to be in your
living rooms and the share in this
weirdness yeah thank you to all of our
health care workers I can't stress it
enough like you guys are the heroes and
we we are indebted to you forever
forever also measured out to the
toasters who are just like using the
toaster groups for good you know
starting Google Docs visiting other
people's grandparents like someone's
grandparents live in Boca this girl went
and delivered groceries like the toaster
groups are obviously so fun like we have
new ones happening every day there's a
new one about movies where it's like
there's a schedule and you could start a
movie at the same time as everyone in
the group and you could live tweet and
there's great things like that but
there's also wonderful amazing
philanthropic things happening and I
just I'm really proud to be a toaster
and I'm proud to be like a head toaster
toast in charge HT I see we are
counselors who are proud of our camp at
rest in peace' head toast but like
thanks to the toasters who are just
obviously contributing to the community
I feel like the groups are keeping
people busy but there's so much more
than just like the surface there's so
much good things going on and thanks to
like everyone who's checking on people's
grandparents you know who live out of
state like that's really it's awesome
and thank you to everyone who is being
responsible and staying home and
self-quarantine and taking this
seriously because the more of us who do
that if we can get a hundred percent of
people taking this seriously we will
flatten that [ __ ] curve y'all
and that's all we're trying to do here
at the toast that's all we're trying to
do next week we will see what happens
like but we should be still doing live
shows yes hopefully well some and we're
just gonna take it one day at a time
together we will get through this alone
together once again there's literally no
other words besides Jordin Sparks
we're just gonna take it one step at a
time
there's no need to rush it's like
learning to fly or falling in love
there's also no other words like tha we
could be alone together
sitting on the edge of carpet that's
[ __ ] fire and that whole album is
[ __ ] delicious that's the song of the
weekend let's start doing a song of the
day chase should be alone together
that's a good one around the corner
that's a good one that's like the
hashtag of the self quarantine is
hashtag alone together and I just feel
like when they do a press conference
like that should be the intro outro song
yeah we should be alone together yeah
well we'll talk we'll talk to our people
we will talk to our people are we done
we're down follow me on instagram before
quality goes off i takeo problems yeah
you can follow me to girl with no job
but if you are gonna save it just go to
claude with no job I could really use
the followers there but like you can
even post there literally never thank
you so is there something else to say
thank you so much for listening to the
morning show some Leno Morning Show we
go live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time on YouTube if you're
watching us on YouTube thank you and
please subscribe give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcasts can be found
so that Spotify iTunes stitcher public
radio I got radio cast box all the
places whoever you listen to podcast
find us the morning show has to leave in
five star view about a beautiful
stunning and smart we are head out head
over to our patreon page rank on slash
morning toast and you know maybe recruit
a toast her this week someone who's
feeling really down could use like a
pick me up every morning at 10:30 a.m.
send them our YouTube and tell them to
subscribe to thank you guys so much of
an amazing day man